i just wanted to clarify what you said
about um the participation and having
everyone on zoom do you mean that
everyone on the roster has been taking
part in the zoom meeting since otas have
started
yes everybody's been on the zoom meeting
including desean watson
i i have nothing to say about deshaun at
this point
poor david cully
he's 65 years old and he gets his chance
and now this is what he steps into an
expansion team
with your best player on strike who you
shall not talk about
especially after he did the podcast
where he
made the mistake of making it clear they
were willing to trade him and then since
then
i think there's there's some device in
play here where any time he mentions to
sean watson there's a button that nick
casario presses to make sure david
culley
recites the line i am not talking about
desean watson
uh but it's just it's just this team
is favored to lose every game
if you go week by week and you look at
the betting lines there isn't a single
game they're favored to win
their points bad odds for the full
season win total is four and a half
i think that's charitable and i would
bet the under it just feels like this
team is listless
the bar couldn't be any lower which is
actually good for david collie and for
the players because everyone expects
them to stink peter but
i i i just yeah i feel bad for david
cully
because he's not going to say no to an
opportunity to coach an nfl team
that begs the question is this even an
nfl team at this point
look you know this is this
sort of reminds me of kind of a tech
startup mic
it really does that you know obviously
they are starting over
the problem with starting over when
you're the houston texans
is that they don't have the advantages
that they had even when they were an
expansion team
uh two decades ago and because when they
were an expansion team they got
they got you know they were able to pick
other players from teams all that
and now they basically
their advantage is not having a draft
pick
you know until the second round
and you know or late whenever they had
it in the 60s
and that to me is the
major reason why they are at such a
huge disadvantage right now they have
none of the edges
that even an expansion team would have
so if four and a half is that number
i mean who knows what's going to happen
that's that's
surprisingly high in in my opinion
and and this is the kind of organization
right now
that from a pr standpoint should be
bending
over backwards to ingratiate itself
to the folks who cover the team you want
those folks
on your side you want them to be rooting
for this ragtag bunch of misfits who are
being slapped together but
when you hire someone from the do your
job patriot way
shut your mouth bill belichick camp in
nick casario
that's not how it goes because he is
wired whether he realizes it or not
to provide as little information as
possible to the enemy of the people
the media so here's the great john
mcclane reacting yesterday to the fact
that
the media got to go to an ota but they
weren't given the information necessary
to understand who in the hell was out
there on the field
getting ready for football season let's
hear directly from john mcclane
let me tell you it was so invigorating
to watch a bunch of defensive players
that we couldn't tell who's who and the
reason was
they gave us rosters with no numbers in
my 45 years of covering
the nfl in houston i've never been given
a roster with no numbers
why would they do that did they leave
them out accidentally
no they don't want us to know who the
players are there's 49 new players on
this roster
so it'd be nice to have some numbers
with the names and be able to see them
but they didn't do it they didn't do it
i've just never seen anything like this
so
i don't know why it's not going to do me
any good to have it so
that's what i think about this roster
that's what you get that's what you get
when look you never
start a fight with the guy who buys his
ink by the truckload that's what you get
when you piss off john mcclane
one of the most respected beat writers
in the country
yeah and it's stupid it's gratuitous
there's no strategic reason
for it what are what are the reporters
going to glean
from an ota session peter where they're
able to match up name and number
what what what secrets of the realm are
going to be shared
with the texans enemies that's the least
of their worries
you could list the problems and concerns
they have one to a thousand
coming in at 9.99 is
the local media being able to connect
the dots between player
and number at an ota session in late may
it's one thing for bill belichick to
slap the number
50 on mac jones he did this week at
practice
because bill belichick has won six super
bowls
he could put the number infinity on mac
jones
he could put pie on max
literally it doesn't matter because he
has won the right
to do silly things as much as he wants
to do
okay but the houston texans
and what they're trying to do is they're
saying okay here's our 49 new players
hey look there's mark ingram over there
he's wearing number whatever he's
wearing 28.
you know and he here's this guy here's
davis mills he's wearing number 11 or
whatever let's take a look at davis
mills hey listen
davis mills is probably the quarterback
of the near term
for this team you know maybe tyrod
taylor this year
but let's look at davis mills see how he
looks
see how he's throwing the ball i just
think it is one of the silliest
things for an organization to do it's
meaningless
it's it's thumb your nose at the media
that covers the team that's what it is
and i have absolutely no idea
why the texans would be doing that right
now
publicly to their team thomas de mitroff
is the only person
from the belichick tree who has been
able to step away from
that that mindset that gets ingrained in
you
by osmosis that this is the right way to
do things that this is the right way to
handle the media
give them as little information as
possible because everyone is the enemy
including
the media and it's going to make it
harder
for nick casario to thrive in houston
and it's just amazing to me
that of all those guys smart guys
competent guys coaches and executives
who have gone elsewhere
they still can't they're so warped when
they come
out of that patriot enclave that they
can't
figure out that that's not the way when
you're not the guy
that already has six super bowl
championships and you gotta build
equity with the media that covers your
team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports